when are they going to take me out from
the back here 100 games out stabbed in
the exactly goodness the big Tech Hunger
Games are underway boys and girls
[Music]
all right Erica's with us in
Jacksonville Florida hey Erica what's up
thank you so much for taking
um so I had a question and it is pretty
much whether or not I should pay off my
car
um I know how it sounds but
um pretty much I have
um 19k in savings right now and there
are 16k left on my car but right now
with the tickets how much left on your
cart let me say it again
oh 16k 16 000 and you have 19 000 in
savings
yes and what do you make and that's not
including in um retirement savings okay
and what do you make
seven BK okay you're single
yes gotcha okay all right
what's your hesitation why don't you
want to pay the car off
um so let's just take layoffs and
everything I just did not want to pay
off the car and then not have any
savings
with what and everything what you're
saying you're saying Tech layoffs do you
work for one of the big tech companies
yes and there's been layoffs at this
company recently
what do you think the percentage chances
you're going to be laid off 50 50 70 30
90 10
.
um I'm honestly not sure they seem to be
random
that's so comforting what a wonderful
place to work on The Chopping Block what
do you make
70 70. what do you do for a living
I'm an I.T security analyst
an I.T what analyst security security
analyst okay good Lord why are you only
making 70.
I.T security is huge
have you shopped around looked at jobs
oh I have and that's my plan but of
course until that happens I just didn't
know no no I want your plan to be like
by Friday
why would you hang out at this place
it's unstable unpredictable and random
that's true and you can make a hundred
working someplace else
that's also true I think so
I got security people working here and
they have i t by their name
could be wrong maybe I'm overpaying them
I don't know
it depends on what you're doing I'm
joking around but I really think you're
in a sweet spot that is a very very hot
field that you're in I don't know what
level of certifications you've got or
how far up in experience you are but I
would be poking around out there and see
what I can find have you heard of Ken
Coleman that is on the Ramsey Show here
that has his own show on careers
oh I have okay have you got any of his
stuff yet because I'm going to send it
to you
I do not I just have your stuff honestly
okay that's fair all right we're gonna
send you his book from paycheck to
purpose
and we're gonna send you the get clear
assessment for career
uh oh and I'll gonna throw in another
book called proximity principle which is
one of his big steps on getting a new
job and I want you to go look for a job
why would you stay there
okay I do understand now why would you
stay there is there a good reason I'm
missing
um
I
I don't know there's a strong reason so
I graduated in 2021
um in the fall so in December and so I
worked here for like a year and a half
okay well Erica here's the deal if you
pay off the car today you free up a car
payment and you just start saving up
that emergency fund again and even if
you do get laid off it's probably going
to be Severance with some cash involved
and so you're gonna be okay so I
wouldn't let this whole thing paralyze
you into not paying off your debt
exactly and here's the thing okay here's
what's bothering me as the old guy in
the conversation okay
I'm doing that a lot today but anyway
the um
I don't want you
because we care about you we love you we
want you to win
I don't want you to have any part of
your life Paralyzed by a company that is
being led poorly
and when they leave their team in a
position of uncertainty feeling that
they randomly could be killed at any
moment
that's what that's where you are they've
left you they've paralyzed your life
your life is on hold while you hold your
breath to see if they're going to shoot
you or not
right
that's true and and I I want more for
you than that that's why I don't think
they deserve you
I think you need to go get something
else for your sake because I don't want
any part of your life on hold because
everything you're just kind of looking
over your shoulder every morning going
when's it coming when's it coming when's
it coming when are they going to get you
know when are they going to take me out
from the back here Hunger Games out
stabbed yeah exactly goodness the big
Tech Hunger Games are underway boys and
girls yeah that's true and you're
waiting for a random email to figure out
that you got laid off I mean there's no
end if you're lucky you know and so what
you've got is let me tell you how bad
their leadership sucks okay they've got
their entire Workforce
thinking like her
that is not a recipe for productivity
loyalty creativity it is not a delivery
of products it's not a recipe for
winning
and so if there's a portion you know
leadership if you've got a real problem
just stand up and go look about 10
percent of you may not make it the rest
of you are safe because we're trying to
turn the corner here on a mess and the
10 that aren't going to make it are
going to kind of look like this and so
if you fall in those categories you
should be you should be holding your
breath the rest of you are okay but they
got the whole stink in place Frozen
because they're wusses as corporate
leaders classic Corporate America crap
it's exactly what you're asking is for
corporate leaders to have integrity
that's asking a lot Dave well I mean you
can be a corporate leader with Integrity
but then you wouldn't be Corporate
America so yeah oh my God it's such a
big just walking on eggshells and how
are you focused at work if you're
worried that it might be your last day
you're not all you're doing is looking
around going well you're at the water
cooler going weird you know George was
here yesterday
uh it's the um the Rapture big Tech
Rapture I feel but you know what our
plan works in good times and bad times
so if that's you out there the best
position you can put yourself in is
being debt free with a fully funded
emergency fund and be looking for that
next thing yeah check out Ken Coleman's
materials they're all Atkin coleman.com
guys and uh hey you know work for a
place that deserves you
and um you know we got 1100 people here
we communicate with them real clearly
can you imagine I ain't scared I'll be
here tomorrow this is the Ramsey Show